[Music]
how's it goin breasts grandma I'm not -
grandma can't you tell taka that's the
modern name at it hold on go get
everyone
glad to be glad I showed him my titties
my grandma did is grandmas awake voice
acting is spectacular as usual oh it is
the grandma welcome back to the calling
I'm a grandma have to make a knowing
annointed Oh missed call Mitch ah isn't
that that ah that's so sweet
I bet it's gonna be super happy ah look
at that she's sooo bad look at I look at
her cute little face I did not have any
he received hidden chapter yes thank you
both for telling me and about 500
messages that I got a hidden chapter so
where's the hidden chapter exactly how
does this work I have to replay
everything you want to override the I
said no why is it saving this will
override the no data I don't want to say
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] I hope I don't
have to replay oh wait this looks
different what's going on press a
no game come on don't tell Matt the
Reaper I will kill something
I will kill something I have to replay
the [ __ ] game to get to define if
it's Sarge for there all right hold your
thumbs rose well you already know if the
video is out then you know the Mahna
Mahna become piece my court oh [ __ ] I
yeah that's it I got to say about that
oh yes new stuff
are we the nipple guy please tell me
where the little guy hey nipple guy how
you doing
look at the owners legs what is wrong
with those leg
yay what is this room where is my nipple
what am I here why are my nipples are
hard
no I have sucked on my leopard for at
least 24 hours definitely wrong here
look he has porn at the bed I saw that I
shot a dad you feel my colleague is
Sadao fell unconscious now their music
in the background a few days later he
died just like the victims in the cases
he was investigating he must have been
close to figuring it all out you
obtained said hours notebook there are
plans to special feature the black page
our next issue so I thought I'd prepare
doing some investigating to be honest in
a lot I can't figure it out but there
are two things that I do know there's a
psycho black fade well we're pretty
[ __ ] the ER that page links will
shatter and I can view the back page
many are Carla because of Lincoln but I
couldn't find any clues yet it seems
that my Dyneema could carry on required
I decided to look into the case is said
to have a cut because to black me
I found this on his desk uh-oh
it led me to the bridge can my nipples
showing it's my nipple showing I
connected to the chat room and then my
nipple fell out and now if talking about
a nipple speedy I'm sorry what happened
to me
[Music]
alright so we're gonna play out this
douchebag see you that goes that goes
yeah yeah all right as we could hand
tied and I brought our mishali the
password is protected
the password is obviously let me right
[Music]
no no you're doing it wrong
[ __ ] you [ __ ] all of you
let's see what's up here
we got bridge treaty being pretty sweet
setup
not only like a lie about a hat give me
exit no we can't got dumb it the
painting hey hey buddy I missed you how
you doing all right sweet Hannah plant
how much just what this is a large TV it
looks expensive
all right just there's something wrong
with the lab perhaps there's something
you want to tell me mr. lamken so what
could the password be maybe the black
page or something let's try that no
that's an A
come on buddy B oh come on oh wait I
can't go back again
black nope
[Music]
acha
please yes
please yes yeah the black page my page
open
good evening are so creepy
good evening uh good evening ah all
right so that's it oh wow packed house
Lola I didn't think that there would be
so many people since your hair I'm
guessing that you heard some rumors
right something like that long why are
all of you here tonight because we heard
a rumor - I want to check it out the
rumors said that you can talk to the
dead I wonder if it's due date 13 we're
talking about the article right I heard
about that magazine - highs and this is
any magazine about I read it all the
time - Lola Lola yar areas regions are
time long yeah hilarious I came here and
this chat room for this totally plain
old shadow blonde yeah actually just
super creepy
I joined looks like a person got into
rumors good evening everyone
oh that's a phone number we're gonna
call it that's the phone number we are
good all right
you can check phone numbers we should
have accompanied by a note I can open I
sing good see bottom I don't know where
that is and even know where to sleep out
of news I have enough phone well that's
the problem I thought I saw one when the
game started no that was the old lady
and I need to find a [ __ ] phone
god damn it maybe it's in here in here
they'd achieve your turn on that's not
creepy at all let's turn it off
okay that's all he got from that really
come on don't do that it's creepy
don't do that
I got a flash and I think there's
something behind this bill ah stop turn
it off please
thank you there's something behind it
sped up I know I obtained a cellphone
yeah yeah alright this guy obviously
likes Marco sure all right
the phone number was however let's try
seven seven seven sevens are really six
eight four seven seven one serious way
I think Morgan brauch
yeah yeah yeah yay it's working
[Music]
oh it's not good all right we teleport
into a bloody kitchen
no it's not a kitchen it's a school
what's going on no I just made a phone
call we already need to know what's
going on and cut the bull crap all right
I'll pick this up no just pick it up
please let's write the [ __ ] in there I
don't care all right can't pick it up
because we can't fit now ordered assume
we can't pick this up either no
impossible it's [ __ ] impossible okay
so we need to find a flashlight
somewhere oh thank you oh there's
blowing from this one I need a key come
on all right so let's find that key but
this looks like a key to me but I can't
see well into the ayats and no thing all
right all right maybe in here can't see
well in the darkness you know like shame
that's a shame buddy
I feel happy for you it's a key in here
maybe me no all right fine that's cool I
don't want to keep
huh we could just hit the light well
we're stashed what are you trying to
pull
stupid attention heart I thought this
might happen but it now it has it's hard
to believe this is just like a beauty
salon I first went to investigate better
seem to have the same place there's no
exit no to be more accurate there's no
door but there's nothing beyond it the
only void no sky and nothingness I
through a magazine that was lying around
just to see what would happen they
banished from my side oh he's talking
about room to hell I call it the Manik
at this shadow town riding shadow
side are you here drift this matter the
door was locked and stuff happened I
don't care good happy for you buddy oh
snap
why just going on that's not good for
anyone
definitely not good hey I plan how you
doing that's a healthy-looking plant
right there all right
oh here it is here it is right there yes
I can usually do okay hello
oh she's cutting hair that's lovely
lovely lovely lovely okay good for now
let's open this stupid Locker yeah yeah
let me pick that I have my party Delos
all right doing probably like about so
not only maybe we can go oh oh oh what
the hell man oh come on hey just [ __ ]
ah come on
could that have been I don't know who it
was but it was that one okay let's go ah
that's not good anyway I'm gonna end
this episode here hope you bros enjoyed
like a failure if you did subscribe to
come a road today and I'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]